Thanks, Rachael.
Excited to be here.
Got 20 minutes to talk, so some
of this might be a little bit
rushed, so I just
want everybody to know
they can reach out to
me if there's my contact
info on the slide and
it'll be at the end
to if they want me to
elucidate on any of the points
that I'm making.
So the title of
this, this talk is
professional financial
reports with R Markdown.
But first, I'll tell you
a little bit about myself.
So I'm a data scientist at a
company called egg country farm
credit, it's a Farm Credit
organization in North Dakota.
We do a lot of egg lending.
I'm a diverse instructor through
the RStudio education group.
If anyone has any
need to learn how
to just teach in general
better and especially
to teach technology,
I would recommend
talking to Rachael about it.
It's a great program.
A few of us went through it
and it's been paying dividends.
So I'm also the author of
the tidy USDA package, which
lets you query the USDA
survey and census data
and then throw them
into nice County
and state maps, which are.
It was kind of a pain
doing that manually.
So I use this every day
at work, and I'm also
author of a slightly more
useful package called Schrute.
And if anyone's familiar
with the TV show The office,
this package has all
of the transcripts
from all of the nine seasons.
So you can create things
like this chart here
that lets that count
how many times someone
said that's what she said,
and obviously, Michael
is the winner here.
This is also available
in Python and Julia.
A lot of people like
using this package just
to practice NLP
and text analysis,
just because it's the data
set that a lot of people
pretty well.
I also had the chance
to use our this spring,
so we had our second,
our second child
and we couldn't decide
on the middle name.
So we use, I think it's
called baby names, a package
and we kind of narrowed it
down to our three names.
We had and we were
looking at the trends
to see how popular they were,
just to make sure we weren't
jumping on the bandwagon.
So it was kind of
a fun thing to do.
I still don't know if my
wife appreciated that or not,
but hopefully she forgot the
pain, medicine and stuff.
But I always like using
her in any way I can.
And this project is
an example of doing
something that may have taken
a few different technologies
in the past, like Photoshop
and some kind of photo editing
thing.
Excel, what have you?
And the goal is to
make a nice packet
for a fictional financial
industry company.
We're calling it
Black swan financial.
So we're.
The output of this will
be three separate packets,
one for each branch
in this company.
And we're going to do
it all in R Markdown.
And the kicker is it's all going
to be PDF outputs because HTML
is arguably a lot easier to
do in R Markdown the PDF.
But unfortunately, people
in the finance industry
still like to print out reports.
So we're going to tackle
that and this is what's
going to kind of look like.
So the key players,
the packages that I'll
be going into a little bit
in this two hour mark down,
obviously is important.
kableExtra lets
us format tables,
which are table format
that we use for PDFs
and lets us set things
up really nicely.
I don't know how I could do this
without this package unless I
knew a lot more about
text, which I don't.
Using the R and I think
that's the package, which
is I think it's relatively new.
It's a nice package that lets
you reproduce your environment
on someone else's computer,
kind of like in Python or Julia.
And it might make installing
my dependencies easier
in your system because Markdown
dependencies can be painful
sometimes.
And then we use the glue package
to glue together bits of SQL
and things like that,
and some strings use that
quite a bit in this example.
Disclaimers like I've been
kind of hinting at R Markdown
is it works great when you
install it on your computer
and get it to work
in your computer,
but the minute someone
else has to reproduce it,
it can be trouble.
So using if you've
never used in package,
you should just be able
to download the repo
from the first page and
hit our end restore,
which should make your
environment almost
identical to mine.
Potentially, you might have to
run reinstall tiny text, which
will fix some kind of
text back end stuff,
and there's more
troubleshooting on the readme.
I tested this on Windows 10 when
I spent 20 and back as well.
OK, so this is kind of the
high level math of what
we're going to be doing.
I like to think of anything
in terms of inputs and outputs
for projects like this.
So the inputs are
these three branches
that we have for our company.
We're going to use one
hour mark on document.
We're going to iterate
over these branches,
pull data from a SQL database,
in this case, SQLite database,
just for an example.
And then when it's
all said and done,
we're going to have a PDF for
each one of these branches
with data for just that branch.
So I'm going to go through
the four pages of the document
here, then we're going to jump
into the code a little bit.
So there's going to be a
front page with personalized.
It's going to personalize
this to show what
branch this package is for.
We're going have just a
really basic income statement.
Another another table
with a ggplot polygon
map just to show that
you can put plots in.
And then this is the same as
the first income statement,
it's just a trend, so just
kind of grouping it differently
in your process.
OK so get into the code.
All right, so if you
folks can see down here,
I'm going to be kind of
navigating this, this file
structure, but I'm going to
I'm going to briefly touch
on how I trade the data
because if someone else, if you
yourself have to create fake
data for a talk like this,
there's a really nice
package called charlatan.
The mix is really simple.
You can create fake
users fake credit cards,
you can fake geospatial
stuff, it's really nice.
So for this example, we're
creating a SQLite database.
We're saving in
the file structure.
We're creating two
tables financials.
So this has kind of the data.
You'd see the income statement,
then a customer's one,
which was on the
page with the map.
And we're just writing
that to this table.
So just making some
simple data that
are really important
to remember that.
But in case you're interested.
They went to the R folder.
So we've got a set up, which
is pretty, pretty common.
I enabled the label, the
name, the main function
that we're going to
run through main.
And then we have a
little functions thing
that has a few functions
and there's an R Markdown
folder, which has R Markdown.
So start the setup.
Got some packages here.
Just calling them
all right there.
I'm pulling the
current year in month
because generally when you
have a packet like this,
let's just say it's income
statements for a branch,
you'd get this monthly, so
it's iterating through that.
I'm creating my connection
to the SQLite database
that I can use later, and I'm
creating my input data frame.
So this is the three
branches that we're
going to iterate over.
So if I run this,
actually, I already ran it.
It's going to show.
Should show.
We're going to show the three
branches that we're going to.
We're going to go over to
Fargo, belfield and kindred,
those are all the
towns in North Dakota.
And so we're going to
run our finished packet
against each of these.
So that's the setup.
Now, Maine, this is where
all the magic happens,
this is where we
source the setup.
The setup file we
just talked about,
we have a function that
will create the reports,
admit them and then put them
in our directory that we want
and then we have an
iterator function.
I'm going to go through
this really quick.
So I create reports function, it
looks at this our main Markdown
report that creates the packet,
it's called report Mastercard.
And in this case, we're using
the R Markdown render function
to take the inputs that we're
going to pass to this function.
It's going to tell us where
we want the outputs to go.
It's going to also
name, name the outputs.
And then it's we're also
specifying the parameters we're
going to use, which are
the magic sauce for this
lets us iterate over
these different branches.
So that's the main function,
and one thing I like to do
is use the per possibly
function instead of a try catch.
So let's say you
have 40 branches
and this packet is huge.
And it takes two
minutes each to do so.
It's a pain to have to
go through 38 of those
and then have it fail
and then you're stuck.
So this kind of lets
you just go through them
and it fails gracefully.
So I have a three year old, and
whenever he wants to ask me,
whenever he asks his mom or me
to do something that we know,
he knows, we're not going
to say he tries to be
as cute as possible, he says.
Maybe ice cream, maybe go for
a walk at 9 o'clock at night.
So that's kind of what I
named this, because it's
what I'm thinking in my head.
Like, maybe create reports.
Hopefully this will work that
kind of helps me remember.
All right.
Silly things like this, so
we're going to take this
is kind of the main generator
iterator part of this.
We're going to take
the input data.
So that was the little data
frame with just the three
records in it.
And we're going to use the perp
walk function to iterate those.
These branches over the
Markdown to create the outputs.
So that's the main our files,
and now we'll get into the arm
Markdown parts of it.
So in the past when I would
make R Markdown reports.
You know, it would
be like 1,000 lines
long because I didn't
know this trick.
So and it was just a pain
because you just be scrolling
and scrolling, trying to find
the things you'd be navigating
with the tree and whatnot.
But there's a nice
way to do this.
There's a little parameter
you can call a child,
so it lets you knit an
individual Markdown document.
And place them all
together into one document.
So I have a separate
Markdown document
for each page of this
packet, so as you
can see, front page
income statement customer
trend on the back page.
So then your main page
looks really clean
and you can kind of
organize it better.
So as far as the
top matter goes,
I have the parameters that
we're going to use here.
These are what we're going
to be using to iterate
ranch months of the year.
I've got a lot of tech
stuff that I honestly
couldn't explain what it
means or how it works.
I just know that after like a
week of getting this format.
The way I want, I have to
have these in this part.
So it's one of those things
that I can't really explain,
but it works.
So copy it.
If you want something
that you might
run to trouble with if you're
on Mac or Linux is the font.
So I change it to
use a sans serif font
and I'm on Windows now,
so I'm using Calibri.
But if you're on Linux,
Ubuntu or what have you,
so you might have an
error that if you just
try to run what I have
playing on Mac or Linux,
so I want to say that.
So let's run through
each one of these pages.
And open up, so front page.
We're taking the parameter
branch and we are.
Passing that to this
function called Create image,
so there's a nice package
called magic and are.
That lets you edit images,
do whatever, in our case,
we're going to be
annotating it with the text
that we're going to see
in the front cover, so.
So this is just literally
a bag of the front page
that we have saved,
but this part right
here, it says Fargo,
North Dakota branch.
This is going to be different
for each one of the branches.
The next one is going to say
belfield and what have you.
So we're going to be creating
this in R Markdown and.
Reusing the glue
package, the glue glue
function to just glue
these parameters together
to create our string.
We're going to throw that string
on that image and return it.
So it's a nice way
to avoid having
to use Photoshop or
some program like that
to create your cover page.
So the next page is the
income statement page.
What?
which is this one?
So it's pretty basic,
it's just a single column.
I've got the date up there.
And as you can see, it's
grouped by different subheadings
and you can see
that it's bolded.
Certain fields are bolded.
And this is the earmark
dump page to do it,
so we're going to be calling
me rather querying our SQL
database that we created
in the beginning, the SQL
like database, I'm
using glue again
to select that data
from the financials.
So grabbing a data
frame at the very top.
And then I'm not going to go
into what each of these are,
but we have the data frame.
We want to change it.
We want to make some
new columns, add up
things, and that's what all this
is so basic data monitoring.
And at this point, you're
going to have data.
That's that's why, right?
So nice and tidy.
But for something like
an income statement,
you want the data
to be vertical.
So there's a nice function
in data table code transpose
that lets you just flip the
axis of your table before we,
we finally put it
into the table.
So this is where
we use kableExtra.
And kableExtra has
a lot of functions
to let you style the
table the way you want.
So in this case, for
each of these rows,
I'm the rows that
I'm aggregating on.
Rather I'm holding them
and this pack rows function
gives us this kind of
nested thing you see here,
which is pretty common
on income statements.
So in a nutshell, we're grabbing
grabbing the data from the SQL
database, we're
managing it and then
we're throwing it into a table
and using kableExtra to format
it, which spits out
this nice looking page.
I'll move on to the
next customer page.
And the best customer rather.
So this.
This is just a simple
table that looks
at the top customers
sorted by interest income,
and then we have just a nice
guy plot that aggregates
that by state and plots it.
So same idea.
We're just pulling the
data from the SQL database
and we're creating
that top table.
And we're just
doing a good plot,
and you can obviously put all
kinds of cool graphs and charts
on here, and the
point of this talk
is to show you how to
use glottis to give you
the idea of how you can
iterate over reports like this.
So last important
page is the trend,
which is identical to the
income statement page,
but we're just grouping
by the date, so we have.
Kind of a the way you normally
see an income statement
with previous months
there, so you can
look for trends and whatnot.
And you also you
will also notice
when you look through this
that this page is horizontal.
And there's actually
have to write,
I think this is Tex or latex.
I'm not an expert on this, but
if you duplicate my report,
you should be able to just
do type this, this command
and be landscape and landscape.
And it lets you have one page
in the middle of your packet,
which is horizontal, which
is huge because this is.
A pain in the butt
to try to form out
to look really skinny, so.
And then we have just a
simple for the back page,
I just literally
have the front page.
Without without all this text
on here, so just a nice way
to bookend the project and just
including the including the PNG
right there and ending it
all together piece by piece.
In this master document.
OK and so I've only got 1
minute left here, but so what,
what can you do with this?
I went really fast.
I didn't have a ton of
time, but like I said,
you can feel free to reach
out to me or fork my repo
or do whatever you need.
What what really helps is in
any financial institution,
you have people usually in
the accounting department
that are making Excel
reports like this
by hand, which
introduces opportunities
for error opportunities.
You know, obviously it's a lot
quicker to do things and are,
you know, you spend six
hours one day creating this
and then you don't have to
touch it forever, essentially.
So it's a good way to pick
up these Excel reports
and also get people that.
That maybe are just cell jockeys
like I was like a lot of us
were and turn them
into our developers
because they see what they can
do with our versus with Excel.
And it really kind of
gets the wheels turning.
You can also make your own
reporting easier as well.
So like if you're a
data scientist like me,
you have to look at various
tables every morning.
And instead of looking at these
tables one by one, you know,
I just have our
marketing reports
that have parameterized
to look at certain tables
and give me the data I need.
So with that, I feel like
I talked really fast,
so I apologize.
But I think we have maybe five
minutes for questions, Rachel.
Yes, that was awesome,
Thank you so much, Brad.
And yeah, we have five
minutes for questions now.
I didn't notice there was
anything in the chat window
yet, but if you want
to ask a question there
through the chat window,
please feel free to go do so.
Or even just ask aloud, it
looks like a lot of people
are just saying that was great.
Brad, Thank you so much.
Great presentation.
Hey, brad, if I could ask
a question real quick.
So how do you automate
this right now?
Is it off of your like
you're using something
like Microsoft Task Scheduler
or our studio's automation
or because that's an issue
we've run into with R Markdown
reports is they don't
run consistently
and we don't have access to
a reporting server right now.
So have you run
into that and then
how have you kind of
solved that problem?
So my day job at a country, it's
a Windows 10 shop, so we don't
have the best windows
isn't my favorite platform,
but what I found
to work the best
is if I make a batch
file and call in this.
In the case of this project,
it would be our script,
our main star.
So you'd be running
my iterator page.
That's I try to make this a
whole project like this roll
up just to one call,
one function call.
So let me pull that
up really quick.
So everything, if
I were to run this,
it would run this whole
process I just described.
And I find if I make a
batch file that does this.
That's the best way
to run on Windows 10.
I like to use Linux
for my personal things,
and putting this on
a Cron job is easier.
We don't have our RStudio
Connect yet at my office,
but I think it's a lot easier
to schedule things like this
with the professional
suite of tools.
I mean, Rachel can say
more about that Yeah
and so with RStudio
connect, you could just
schedule this to run as often as
you needed it to and then email
out to specific people
that needed to receive it.
Or I'll put a I'll just
put a link in the chat
too, if anyone
wants to look at it.
Awesome Thank you.
Another question in
the chat is, brad,
what about requests to drill
into individual transactions?
Do you get these
from your users?
So so is the question kind of
scope creep based on the report
that I've created, so let's say
we have this income statement
report.
I think the question
is, do we have
people asking to drill
into these things further?
And if that's the case,
yes, all the time and.
That's more of a person
Management thing than a data
management thing, but
with our Mark down reports
like this that are
spinning out PDFS,
it's a little bit tougher
because you have to.
Once you have this format down
and it's creating these tables,
it's.
A little bit tougher
to change versus
if you were spending
on it, you could
use all kinds of
different frameworks
like GTI that let you drill
into things a lot better.
So, you know, you
lose flexibility
when you're spinning
on to a PDF.
My opinion?
And there's a few
other questions
in the chat trying
to read through which
ones haven't been answered yet.
But someone had asked
for any recommendations
for learning latex
books or websites.
I don't know latex, I know
the are Markdown book.
Books that you use
put out, maybe Rachel
can post those in the chat
or something or something,
but the author of R Markdown
has a really, really good book,
and I based my learning on
making parameterized reports
on his little chapter
that he has in there.
I just had to expand
on a lot because it
was kind of bare bones,
but that's where I start.
As far as, like
learning latex proper.
I don't have a clue.
Some it looks like Nick put
a helpful link there, too.
And I think we have time
for one more question.
I see Louise just
asked my question is
more culture related?
Did you encounter any
resistance to start
using R four reports instead
of Excel or outdated report
writers?
Oh Yeah.
I tell people when I first
started at my current company,
there was no one using our.
There was no one using any
language like this period
and was all Excel.
And it was.
You know, I was pretty
confident in my capabilities,
it was spreading
evangelizing people
on telling them that our is
better because we can do things
like this and you're not
going to have people fat
fingering errors that
cost millions of dollars.
So it's.
The evangelism part
is really the kicker,
and you have to have you have
to develop people skills,
and in the end, you
really have to show
what's in it for those people.
I mean, because you
and I know that our is.
For certain things are
as better than excel,
right, you just have to show the
value and then people get it.
Awesome, Thank
you so much, Brad.
It's funny with
virtual meetups, not
like clapping for
everybody, so I'm
going to clap, but
Thank you so much.
And we'll have a
few more minutes
at the end of the meetup for
a few other questions, too.
But if there's anything
that didn't get answered,
we can continue using the meet
up discussion page as well.